[Music]
what's happening is he unhatching I
think he's being born I'm so weak oh
yeah I'm doing everything I can to be on
the show today
it's okay it's okay we'll start you guys
welcome back welcome back to the break
room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all nerdy news you need to
know and Tommy's health because it's
always declining Tommy is barely with us
today it's barely with us oh that
non-animal organs he has coming up we
have Thor Thor gives up some meat oh God
and not the meat that we're all begging
for but we wish black panther 2 and Loki
two updates because we know we need them
and we finally get to talk about Miss
Marvel's finale and how we are all shook
by a certain tune remember that today's
Redemption is still Thor themed for
every hundred dollars we will be
swearing but in honor of the guy who
puts the as an Asgard Thor we will be
using this jar of old Viking squares
over there it's over there if we hit a
thousand dollars remember Tommy at the
end of this week we'll get his hair cut
and whatever we want it to be and we
will come with us if he's still with us
let me see if he makes it and if we do
2000 we'll go see the Minions movie and
by we just Zach I also did the theater I
did the theater not to do and I'm
chewing gum so while I'm introducing
everyone this is Brenda Barrick oh hello
uh I'm vamping just so that someone can
do something but not spit out their gum
oh there you go yay also I'm Jessica
Clemens and here's my dead uncle Tommy
bechtels oh great camera camera Fork oh
no oh
yes the giraffe pancreas didn't take
and I was forced to lay up in a hospital
bed while they searched for another apex
predator to put inside of me and let me
tell you they tried everything I was
split open like a Thanksgiving turkey so
they kept stuffing me with that good
Stouffer stuffing a shark pancreas a
rhino pancreas a unicorn pancreas a Cree
pancreas but in the end
the pancreas of a virgin is what it took
my own pancreas that was still in my
body because I felt bad about giving it
up dear Lord yeah I did one more second
I can't help but notice you know you
don't think I've been watching but I've
been watching I've been in the chat
I under I mean I assume no one's wearing
Pockets because you've been a little
tight fisted lately so you must have
your coin purses somewhere else let's
give a little more generously your trash
bags I gotta be honest this audience
doesn't deserve me and if I don't see
that ticker going up
I'll be out again and I'm taking
everyone with me and this will just be
the room this will be the break room
this will just be the room and not the
fun movie that everyone yells at and not
the scary sad movie with Brie Larson
either okay it'll just be a blank room
so do the right thing open up those
coffers and give us an offer
and of course
I'm here I I
agree us but I hope I don't have any
organ needs after that terrifies
I'm ready to live I'm ready to live
please I hope I end this show a lot
let's see carry on as I've been well
let's carry on Brave Warriors it's time
for the headlines oh my goodness
Mmm delicious tears of the haters it's
the second best phase four movie here's
the first headline for you Rotten
Tomatoes Awards editor Jacqueline Coley
recently interviewed Daniel kaluya who
announced he won't be returning for
black panther wakanda forever due to
scheduling conflicts with nope oh that's
crazy I think it's crazy but I also
don't mind it because he ended it kind
of uh a butt hat yeah yeah at a rough
rough Landing there at the end he was a
butthead in that movie but no it's okay
if he would have came back for sure but
I I don't mind him yo I'm off screen no
did I want Daniel in the movie
nope oh oh take that headline for free
that is it got him next headline hey
Natalie Portman revealed doing an
interview that Chris Hemsworth stopped
eating meat for their on-screen kiss
she's a vegan of course uh I don't know
why I said of course she just is uh
here's the quote she had in the
interview uh quote the day we had a kiss
scene he didn't eat meat that morning
because I'm vegan and he eats meat like
every half hour uh like so that was
thoughtful she was going to make a very
thought she didn't demand that he'd do
it okay he's just being nice the guys in
he's an okay shape yeah I bet he eats
like the rock where it's like I have to
eat yeah this whole fish by like all the
time and then work out and then I have
to eat another pig at like 12. I I feel
it yeah so that's why it definitely is
probably like everything I saw the
headline like gives up I thought he gave
up meat for like a month cleanse himself
no that just made me thinking it made me
think of every lie that I've ever told a
girl like it really made me think
somebody did not give up like every lie
that I've ever told woman to like make
her like me more like I I didn't uh I
didn't sleep on the floor again last
night no I didn't drink last night I
only smell like vodka her vodkas doesn't
really have a notice let's pick a better
one John cut that out I smell like
tequila because of the mouthwash that I
use oh you're smelling uh coconut rum
because of my sunscreen things of that
nature no I didn't sleep with your
sister we didn't do a lot of sleeping
camera four real quick come on got it
all right next headline next headline
hey variety reported that sources from
Marble said there were plans for Haley
Steinfeld to return as gay Bishop in the
MCU uh there's no official announcement
been made yet but like they were saying
like we're hearing it it's it's coming
it's happening I think we all assumed
this would happen but now they don't
sign people for like 10 pictures and
three shows and they just kind of pieced
me like what do you guys think we're
gonna see uh the gay Bishop again next
like Echo want the Mania maybe She-Hulk
I think it could be a little while I
think the way they're going with the
storyline is the I think if the young
vendors happen which I strongly think it
will she'll be like the pseudo leader
she seems to be the of that team her
Amanda Lonnie have that downiness they
have that like charismatic carry a team
lead quality so I could see her coming
back when they need someone to put the
team together and that might honestly
start being maybe as soon as she'll can
post credit scenes because I do think
we're going to talk about Miss Marvel a
lot but I do think the way Shield's
gonna go is dealing with the legislation
side and that could get boring so they
might need to start doing some elements
of World building that way the people
because it did the other day weird the
advertisement for stuff like it's the
it's the Easter eggs it's the buzz it's
all those things week to week so they're
gonna need to start doing week to week
moments to build the audience
constant buzz like living in a bee so I
don't think it's in a shield but I think
something in that vein of like when they
need to start reminding us like Young
Avengers right right because we don't
have the team up movies announced no
like by this point I think in the in the
previous phases we would have had an
Avengers coming in down the pipeline
where you're like we're going to see all
these people again now it's just no
man's land it's anyone anyone goes
that's crazy I never know maybe she'll
show up on Baymax Big Hero 6 who knows
they do like to say the people will
return yeah
Thor just say like Thor will return Yes
it didn't say win yes no no but Miss
Marvel did say because we know her movie
is the combination of movies oh sorry so
Noob Master just donated 69.
master and I just it dropped my it
dropped my jaw well you just got to draw
you just figured out
yes cross the straws right here 69
exactly and you will stop me in my
tracks yep now we get the curse we do
four-ish I think to add um more to this
we should curse and then eat the paper
oh I don't I'll eat the paper I'll get
everybody's Pizza Tommy's got a fresh
pancreas which is just his old thing
it's true I get one too yeah thank you
master he did ask who would you vote to
narrate your life story Korg or Lewis oh
I think I like Korg a little more
if you get more you
more
yeah
oh yeah sorry
I'm a fast talker I feel like the energy
my friend out of chaos
like as a person I'm more like him yeah
I would go with Luis as well because I'm
a Bastion of Truth and and righteousness
and Luis has a tendency to exaggerate so
I feel like he wouldn't have to
exaggerate as much for me because
everything I do is awesome already I'm
very Layman so I want mine to be ran by
Valkyrie and her to give up halfway
through she's like ah just just look
just deal with extra sex I'm cork all
right do some person quick I got more
headlights I'll get one get going
um you are
I'm so glad that you I should have
inborn of you it means unborn oh you
kill like that's like on a live or
whatever oh I kill them maybe all right
well I have to say there's been some
good people in the audience that have
restored my faith in this what I will
say generally terrible audience that we
have but some of them have been real
Hawk neffers which is of course a hawk
nose which I guess is an insult I wish I
had a hawk nose I know yeah
uh you know guys I can't dance I'm a
real berlifter wow
do you know that someone being a clumsy
foot is
what they meant to me but now I know
it's my grandmother's name
uh I got Rella which is Grime and I got
a lot of relics
hot noses in the chat out there Thank
you new master for the 69 donation but
no thank you to those swear words we're
gonna need another 100 in the batch
because we gotta do that again there was
not a single good curse word I got
another headline okay all right next
headline in an interview with variety
Euphoria actress Sydney Sweeney says
Madame Webb has begun filming she did
not offer any information about her okay
I like that just cold announcement yes
okay the filming has begun she's just
got nominated for two Emmys she's cute
congratulations hey next headline a few
new She-Hulk images have surfaced online
including a new look at the She-Hulk CGI
they're still tweaking it uh and then
Jamila jamel's character Titania Titania
right now uh and one of Jennifer Walters
with torn clothes in the courtroom uh
that could get you held a good time
you gotta respect the courtroom do you
think Jamila is another uh lawyer
she dresses up in her leg outfits I
don't care
if I was um if I was a superhero like
Jennifer Walters once you figure out
that you're like also like have Hulk uh
I would absolutely be in my outfit in
the lawyer room all the time oh yeah
exactly it's intimidating it's a great
Factor you pay attention if I'm frozen
caveman won't ever taught me anything so
you played your strengths that's right
you bring up that you're an unfrozen
cake and that helps you win cases sure
that's for all you Google it put it in
on YouTube guys come on the same boat
Avril I agree with your comment uh and
our final headline for today we also got
some new set photos from Wilkie season
two producer John refuses to show them
to you here okay because they're they're
uh they're uh they're just ads for
McDonald's would you say that when he's
talking about the set photos he's
keeping it low-key
I still be working as a McDonald's
employee in the 1970s uh a big ball from
gracer and that would explain her anger
because having to work at like a
customer facing job like that cannot be
fun be nice to people out there folks
just be kind to each other and all be
kind to each other [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
someone called that in the chat they
said if we if we just keep swearing in
the chat they'll just naturally start
swearing it's inevitable it's osmosis
have to be better you have to be better
yeah I'm a child I'm such a child I'm
playing with this tape that's very
expensive yeah and it's not audio
friendly and you keep ripping pieces of
it do we need to get you a fidget
spinner
it's really hard let me have your
glasses we will say we did ask the
checks eating me to kiss Natalie Portman
uh 59 say yes 40 said no I stopped
eating me yeah I starved to death I mean
she's married I don't want to disrupt I
love me like it's actually hotter for me
if she is married up to two or three
days of not eating at all for Natalie
portal it's like just I will go on any
sort of place like meat I really like
meat man there we go oh my god when you
can have meat at home I wonder if you
could like vegan protein though like did
he have like like what did he do because
he let that usually mean and light yeah
don't worry about it his mouth is clean
sunflowers butthole he's just flossing
out turkey that he had like moments ago
[Applause]
alligator turkey everyone's sporting the
story today and be like such a good guy
yeah
I was just saying and passing I know
it's a headline and that was a headline
yeah he's just doing this like a Barbara
he's like you know it didn't eat me it's
a line but now it's like we're gonna
give him a national medalized for good
meat the entire day your guys your both
of you guys impression of him it was
very good I cannot do an Australian
accent no I haven't tried for a reason
we can sit uh the promo for the finale
Miss Marvel promise that the episode
would change everything oh my gosh
um this is on me and I'm so sorry I
didn't know wait wait am I wrong no
you're right oh my gosh I'm so sorry you
guys I I'm really sleepy today's a hard
day for me and when I repeat this I read
it from a prompter and I'm so sorry
sorry wasn't the best quality is going
on I'm sorry I'm so sorry this is on me
the promo for the finale Miss Marvel
promise that episode would change
everything and it did big spoiler if you
haven't watched the finale of Miss
Marvel but three two one
can I still say it yes
he's a mutant yeah I feel bad I wanted
to talk about it so bad today and I
don't know what the limit is on when you
can post about it on Twitter is I just
did lots of spoilers all caps like
because everyone is already and I didn't
use any hashtags I tried to be a part of
the problem not the I mean yeah
X-Men and mutant has been trending on
Twitter all day so yeah Twitter is not
part of that problem so
12 10
already on Twitter it was Captain Marvel
so I was like okay I think I'm fine
right right I think I'm fine but I still
watch I still watch uh though she would
be definitely confirmed oh sorry uh but
nope she's got a mutation going on okay
there you go an article on marvel.com
today quoted members of the cast and
crew as they learned that the big reveal
would be happening on the Miss Marvel
series and apparently was not always the
plan from the start which I'm not
surprised yeah it came about during the
writing of the show head writer bishek K
Ali said uh when the idea of how Kamala
was genetically uh different from the
rest of her family it fit into the logic
of a wider MCU so why do we think that
Marvel is just now starting here with
the mutants this is a big deal because
it's like I chose Miss Marvel right
right we yesterday we were all like oh
she'll be inhuman no way they would say
she's living at all I I thought in the
beginning this was going to lead to
means because it's the I think it's the
perfect place to do it because it's a
show about Prejudice like it's literally
a show that I think this needs to set
the tone so I was saying this was going
to set tone for mutants I didn't
necessarily know it was what they did
but I think as far as like they had the
mosques with it no no they had the
mosques with the government watching
them in surveillance they had literally
children being hunted by a government
agency they've had all of these things
it is X-Men like the show's already
X-Men so why not have you live with a
mutant for six weeks to already
establish that World 100 I think it's
genius I think that I think I hope
everyone is getting that same exact buy
because I think I when I watched it I
was like oh what an honor I didn't even
think about like this is a show that
does have a lot of prejudice
I was like oh this is so good for her
I'm glad when she looked at her
reflection in the mirror in the full
outfit I almost cried just because I was
like she made it so far it's just
another label line is the X-Men to me
like when she when she said it's just
another label I was like oh they know
exactly what the comic books was doing
and they're giving us long slow burn
which is what you need with the X-Men
like the X-Men is going to be this
phases Avengers I think and you need to
slow build that and earn it because
everyone wants phase four be like phase
one and that doesn't work you do things
like this and you surprise us and you
have to be cohesive when we're not
expecting it do you uh do you what was I
gonna oh do you think that they they
which I think is kind of weird do you
think it was too much to play the X-Men
90 no no oh you don't think it was too
much I was so happy I thought I thought
it was I thought it was a nice touch
I didn't even catch it and so that was
my my friend was watching it was like
did you hear the song and I was like I
didn't need to hear the song I know what
she said that means it wasn't too much
because you didn't hear the song yeah if
they cranked it up another 30 percent
okay
that's what I'm watching is someone
watching the cartoon in their apartment
right next to it yeah
um but I thought it was just like more
so I was like do you think they had to
double down because people wouldn't have
understood I think it was like I guess
we said that they did that for Charles
Xavier and yeah and Multiverse of
Madness too they played the X-Men
Stinger also it's a matter of of
conversation of a lot of people are
already like yeah but in humans could be
a mutation because the Mist I think they
needed to be like we mean this yeah and
also as I was saying a second ago like
we're the advertisement so what's gonna
get a bigger Rush the word or the word
and the song Here we are and I think a
lot of this I think them choosing to
start kind of here with this show which
is aimed at a you know I think that
every their whole audience but like
certainly like a younger audience that
you know there's people if you're a kid
well you want to get into Marvel movies
that have already existed for 15 years
it's like well I'm starting here and you
know marvel has not been doing a lot
with the X-Men because they were owned
by Fox for so long yeah they stopped
making the comics that's why they really
started doing Inhumans again so it makes
sense to kind of like if we're gonna
have to explain everything to everyone
let's start and a show that's bringing
more people into the MCU is right now a
good time to go back and try to read the
comics for X-Men uh yeah I mean I'm
always recommend all the time do you
mean the current runs or no just to go
back and just just get into it Amy X-Men
is always relevant because the world's
always shitty
I know for me specifically I do read the
comics that I haven't read like based
off of what's coming so like for um uh
Echo I started going into those Comics
or like iron heart I was like oh I need
to go back into these but uh X-Men it's
like I know some should I go back and
maybe get another I before I read like
things that seem like they'll grow into
this storyline since typically like God
loves man kills I guarantee he's going
to come to play because the deals the
government like oversight I would read
ease for extinction because that's going
to deal with like the ideas of the new
X-Men wave the grant Morrison Frank
Whiteley run and that's going to be like
Sentinels and things that I assume
they're going to do because they did in
the last run and ease for extinction
does a lot of great things about like
what it means to identify as mutant and
then I'd also read
um the the Joss Whedon run started
really strong with that gifted Arc and
gifteds about like people not wanting to
be a mutant so they like depower
themselves and I think that might be a
conversation with Kamala because we saw
a bunch of kids fighting and being like
wait children with powers and that ties
into the dod say anything I've been
writing about I'd read those kids
astonishing X-Men I always recommend it
so good start so and it's the best guy
astonishing whatever reason 25 issues
it's beautiful just the The Arc I
mentioned is only six but the entire 25
issue run the art is stunning the
writing's spectacular Joss Whedon can
make some Life Choices differently it
would be nice but yeah yeah good writing
yeah some good writing a good writing
separate the Arts from the artists
that's my uncle who is my
so is Kamala gonna be the initial wave
or do you think there's already been an
older generation we just haven't seen
yet I mean clearly we know there is uh
Charles Xavier in a different timeline
but do you think in our I guess do you
think in our timeline there's no other
ones I mean I hate to like
I know that this was kind of a maligned
resolution but the fact that Evan Peters
did play even as Ralph boner right
implies that that is what that character
should look like in some capacity and in
some universe so I I feel like there are
going to I think they're they're
crawling out of the woodwork rather than
I'm fine with there being some mutants
out there already but like don't tell me
that like Xavier school for the yeah
yeah it has existing sure sure and no
one's been talking about it or that like
there's been a crew running around I
mean I think like uh make alpha flight
have been around forever like they're
the young man
it actually kind of makes sense though
like have some of the like no one can
about the Canadian Avengers because you
know it's Canada who cares right and
it's like objects
yeah yeah you guys haven't been to
Canada like I have stuff goes down there
oh sorry stuff goes up there yeah it's
America's hat oh
oh you guys it's all coming together
but also how do you want them to be I
feel like we always ask this but I want
to know how you think they're going to
be introduced now or like what bigger
introduction do you want I think after
this there's gonna be someone She-Hulk I
think that's like a great way to just be
like here's a couple more yeah they're
also in prison and like or like they
need legal help or something like that
that makes sense especially doing this
now I think it's a great way to like be
like hey you're going to want to check
out for sure I slapped you because I
agree with she holds because the dodc
yeah they're gonna start persecuting
people with the X Gene that's what's
gonna like it's literally gonna be
separating people by species which is
going to be the race parallel the comics
are sometimes like the lgbtq
identification of the X-Men plus the
racism implications are so perfectly
timed to both She Hulk a green person uh
but also like the character she's going
to be representing is I'm the first
public facing superhero so she's going
to be publicly facing as a superior
defending people like the X-Men like why
you have to it's I I I'm sure it's I
want to make sure we get all your guys's
questions in there so we can answer them
at the end of the time end of the video
we want to save time so we answer each
and every individually one of you but I
also we will get more into uh Miss
Marvel at the end of the episode this
was our talk about mutants and because I
do want to explain I want to get into
agent Cleary so bad I want to get into
whatever the hell he's talking
about I'm Eric oh wait actually we do
have something from TD Jones I will do
this one really quick does this mean in
humans don't exist in the 616 MCU
I think they could go that route because
like Kirby wrote the Inhumans so you
could tell the like the more wonky wacky
crazy X-Men stories whereas if you're
gonna do X-Men and the MCU you're gonna
follow a certain streamline I don't know
if you need necessarily in humans the
reason humans have been popular lately
even as far as making the TV show is
because of the fox deal so they Marvel
pulled X-Men toys they pulled X-Men
merch like there was a lot of stuff that
wasn't available and the X-Men Comics
were taken down from like 12 titles to
two so in humans became popular because
of avoiding them Wolverine yeah they
killed Wolverine for years but like the
void in the market caused the Indians
surge of popularity if you don't I'm not
saying in humans are a lesser thing I'm
saying if you don't focus on you can't
focus on both and I think right now
where the Creed never right experimented
on like prime mortgage and Blackpool was
a great moment for the fans of Indians
be like Hey Kevin feige knows you guys
care about Black Bolt that could be like
a fun thing is like if in this year
Universe the CR the humans don't exist
but they're about to because the Korean
now are going to start doing it and the
secret Warriors
in the chat said does Bruno equal
Charlie's Xavier and it was lol no
but I would love that more than anything
if he goes and studies and then he's at
the like we just pick up in first class
he's just now going to college you know
you have a certain mutation in fact a
rather groovy mutated
he's like I'm British and you know what
super groupie making your own meals at
home and that's why we want to shout out
our friends at hellofresh America's
number one meal kit they're sending farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes right to your doorstep
or if you don't have a doorstep whatever
is right there in front of your door you
can choose from over 55 weekly options
so you can Savor summer flavors right
from your beautiful Abode uh Tommy you
made some Hello fresh I said hello fresh
and since the last time hello fresh
sponsored this show I've been a loyal
subscriber I use that that code that I'm
going to talk about or you'll talk about
in a moment to get my meals my free free
meals and my free gifts the gifts keep
on giving the gift of health is the gift
that you can't quantify I had some beef
flautas the other day I made some
pan-seared Italian chicken with those
potatoes I love a lot of potato for an
Irish boy like me the potato Centric
meals I know not necessarily something
you want to make is the centerpiece of
your meal but they give you just enough
they give you four you cut them up my
girlfriend she's little she only eats
like one like half a person's worth so I
eat her other half I'm getting one and a
half percent
that's right three potatoes forget one
for her that's right yeah Chicken in
every pot Brandon take it away beautiful
wow I hello Fresh Market is a One-Stop
shop for all your meal time needs with
quick breakfast lunches snacks desserts
and more if you don't want to join the
cooking there's some pre-made stuff that
you can get uh I love these services
like hellofresh it's great and also
here's a little tip uh if you're someone
of a pro Chef like myself just keep a
couple other ingredients in your fridge
toss them in there and now it's yours
yes you you steal it from them like Andy
Warhol making his students make his
paintings for him yeah you just take it
it's mine now I created this we call you
the aggregate Chef I'm the aggregate
Chef folks uh but check out hello first
they're really awesome it's a great way
to support us here at the break room
just go to hellofresh.com break room 16
1 6 and use code break room 16 that's
one six for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts uh who loves a free
gift I do that's code break room 16 for
up to 16 free meals and three free gifts
oh and we also want to thank our friends
at athletic greens yeah it's no secret
that I've battled some health issues
recently I tested positive for the
Barona virus that's when you can't stop
quoting Everybody Loves Raymond I don't
want to go to the dance recital Raymond
you're lucky you even have a family
anyway we also want to uh I started
taking AG once I wanted better gut
health I wanted to feel better I need
more energy and now I've been on it for
two months and I love it I'm reading it
in the past that's because I wrote this
copy for when I wasn't going to be here
but you're here delicious scoop of ag-1
just one little Scoopy in there oh baby
I don't even have to make a face because
it tastes good you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Foods
Super Foods baby this pancreas is
rocking what size your pancreas on it
might be up here for all I know it's a
special blend of ingredients to support
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy your recovery
your focus and not something I deal with
but I hear aging is a factor for other
people you're ageless that's right I
have the tendons of a thoroughbred horse
and that's not a lie it contains less
than one gram of sugar no GMOs No nasty
chemicals artificial anything it still
tastes good maybe I'll take another sip
[Music]
um
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit the
athleticgreens.com break room
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athleticgreens.com break room to take
ownership of your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
cheers everyone Cheers Cheers
that's pretty much it for me I'm spent
psych it's time for mandatory fun oh no
that's right the segment I've been
missing so much I just gotta stay in
touch hit my graphic again
uh did we cross a threshold for a viking
Square by the way no okay
you know uh maybe on the Super Chat
yeah we're at 426 guys I mean let's do a
quick Viking swim before I introduce
mandatory fun and really dig deep on
this one oh yes
okay
I'll go first yeah okay this is a lot uh
when I think of the average uh place
that someone who watches our show uh
they're dead I assume it's in their
parents basement uh caked with uh Little
Debbie's Mountain Dew Code Reds that
they spot bootleg off the black market
and smelling of fritters or farts oh
farts that's a good one we were talking
about this earlier in a good way but I'm
gonna say Brandon you're a handsome
hey hey why don't you go make yourself a
sandwich you proud nepher that's a bread
nose
bread nose they really yeah
right in the face in the center they
know how to hurt you you know Chris
Hemsworth claimed he went vegetarian for
at least half the day but I feel like as
long as the scourgea was Daphne it's
okay as long as the young cow was Dopey
it's fine
that's right I've never called someone a
young cows
I forget who narrates it but it's really
good Morgan Freeman that's right yeah
that's good work ever since I was a
young cow I can't it's not right I'm
sorry anyway it's time for mandatory fun
hit the graphic again to remind us
right there oh boy anyway
we all know as we saw Miss Marvel
everyone watched it and we loved it I
enjoyed it I I brought a tear to my eye
I did Tara and I also got that last
fight scene was uh like the standoff
scene was emotional we got to another
Square we'll do it at the end but for
those of you that stuck around for the
credits as I do I gotta know who that
best boy is I gotta know who that key
grip is I gotta know dude industrial
Light and Magic get their little fingers
in there make a make a special effect
who knows you got to see the
post-credits scene in which we all saw
Ms Marvel
we know it's called Freaky Friday
Brandon what do we call it I call it a
Saturday swap we call not a Freaky
Friday Saturday swapped
with uh with Captain Marvel forgot her
name for a second
read about this stuff
you got their names to me they like the
passage of time they just keep moving
along anyway she Saturday swapped not
quite a Freaky Friday freaky in its own
right though and let's face it freaking
Brie Larson those go hand in hand you've
seen her tick tocks she's a wild one
anyway it gave me the idea
to uh Saturday swap some of our favorite
Marvel characters into other non-marvel
movies so I let's where would you like
to see other characters land in in just
the Cinematic Universe out of the MCU
anyone want to take this first uh I'll
take I'll take a straight and they swap
we will keep the actor the same okay you
take black widow yes and you put her in
Lost in Translation oh and she has the
same night or the same experience with
Bill Murray but the whole time she's
also killing people wow is when she's
still doing assassin For Hire stuff in
the beginning he helps he helped her
experience with him helps her break out
of her her hypnosis whatever he whispers
at the end
yeah
I like that uh I'm gonna go with I one
of my favorite things about the Deadpool
comics I'm counting in the MCU he's
coming uh one of the same thing with the
devil Comics is when they put him in
like crazy hijinks and like situations
sometimes they have to go back in time
to the 70s sometimes they put him in
team-ups with characters from another
era I want to keep him in the modern but
I want to put him specifically in a
movie where he would Thrive but I can
see this as a one-off and that is fear
and loathing
Las Vegas
that's the beauty of it he can take
every drug and his body would process it
so quickly so what the movie's plot is
is he's trying to go through the whole
trunk of drugs himself so Johnny Depp's
trying to keep up with Deadpool in Vegas
and they're both seeing what limits the
bodies can handle somewhere past
Barstool Barstow Barstow we're on
Barstow the drugs kicked in is that what
it was we can't stop here this is Back
Country yeah but it's him seeing Batman
yes oh Batman
it's right there Benicio del Toro's in
it but he's as his character and
Guardians the Galaxy
up in the car buddy Spider-Man has Peter
Peter prior in Deadpool's little
relationship that might happen oh my God
that's the uh what's that movie at the
Peach
um by your name call me by your name
with Deadpool and Spider-Man also yes
Army hammers there to eat people actual
cannibal Army Hammer yes
confirm cannibal confirmed red arrow uh
go ahead Jessica there's so many movies
and I space for a minute because I was
like oh we came up with I came up with
so many so many movies and I can't
choose between the two so I don't think
I should be in the running because I'm
coming up with two right now okay but I
think a fun one to do would put uh
nebula in Westworld because they would
think she's a robot but she's like I'm
more human than I am bro this must be
another host they have to do what you
want why don't you meet me upstairs yeah
cut to her cutting it yeah literally
cutting it's not like stabbing someone
to death the old yo Brenner uh uh yes
oh okay and then um my other one is
still the nebula I think would be so fun
to do an MCU version to Space Jam oh and
then like the you know how in Space Jam
they have the [ __ ] mountain or the
[ __ ] yeah it would be just the aliens
from the ncu so it'd be like nebula
Gamora oh my God the monsters
is penguin in this this penguin still
have his powers still playing basketball
and
his power
yeah this is my magic yeah this is my
magic that's actually a great idea uh I
love that let's do it wait okay we're
going with what Brandon said okay those
are all great answers unfortunately
there was only one correct answer and
that was you put Drax the Destroyer in
the movie Shrek uh as Shrek get out of
my swamp
I'm like an onion you have to peel back
the layers to understand me donkey Fiona
just all this like Shrek doesn't talk a
lot in the first movie Drax doesn't talk
a lot in the movie oh my god when they
talk it matters there's great ones in
the chat man this isn't A Bug's Life
okay I guess I'm talking about mine I'm
sorry no Jessica I'm sorry you know what
I've been back for one day and you're
acting like a mind Frederick a steak
fart but look here you stupid Tonga well
that means you just have a tongue yeah
yeah
you're stupid oh this one's good for you
oh no it's not handsome uh it's past 500
we could do another round of this that's
what we did that's what we're doing okay
these are all very offensive now you can
say it out loud their Vikings you have
to say it to me you can be nice to me
and let me finish my pitch
that's fine no
oh yeah yeah Corpus yeah it's a drunkard
and it's all if it's true it's just real
the man went on a 20-minute rant about
the different smells alcohol again yeah
that's
true I want to also give credit to
Zachary fine your in the chat that was
my second pick was over in Jurassic Park
because it's like that Savage lands
dinosaurs he is the T-Rex as a T-Rex
obviously I also want to put Spider-man
an alien oh that's fun I like that
attack line would be in space no one can
hear you swing
Chrissy says that mind freder does not
mean stink fart although that is
according to this spreadsheet that I
downloaded off the internet with no
vetting so Chrissy what does it mean it
must be true but Chris Evans as
homelander and the boys 100 yes oh
that'd just be funny all right is that
the end of mandatory fun that's it for
mandatory fun hit the graphic one last
time
uh great because we want to get to all
your questions all your ideas and your
thoughts uh a couple quick things uh we
did some polls in the chat are you
excited Kamala is that mutant or would
you rather be an inhuman you all want
the Mutant baby yeah we're all happy
that she's a filthy Beauty how could she
uh and where do we think mostly hailee
Steinfeld next 51 of you think Echo I
mean it makes the most sense
are we doing a hostage at the local
Boston IHOP where else respect she gets
it no get out yeah that's right they
never should have changed it from IHOP I
loved when it was the house of burgers
uh and the chat also koi they loved your
Freaky Friday yeah it was technically a
swapping Saturday
my Saturday swap was sliced in half like
Solomon slicing a baby in half because
Jessica just didn't want to let me
finish I didn't even get my name in the
polls so I guess we're even okay fair
enough
yes that's fire yes good job thank you
Dodson for defending me no no I don't
have a good you guys it's fine let's
answer something okay so Edward Puck had
a Super Chat thank you Edward uh what if
the mutation is the inhuman Gene because
in the comics they do say it is a
mutation uh there is like weird
combinations of it in humans immune I
know like if a mutant gets Terra Genesis
it like can take away their powers also
they can also like kill them yeah it
usually kills them because that's that
war that happened was the Inhumans
versus X-Men but also the new humans
which is like an evolution of the
Inhumans right it's Comics there's a lot
of things weekly you gotta write a lot
it's a good crew for me because I don't
know a ton about the comics comics and
you guys are experts this is good can I
just ask a few questions shut the camera
it's the real breakthrough who's the
Hulk and what does he do uh but I do you
know then what is he who is your father
what does he do what does he do I do
think like the Muse being here it's
great I love it I do think it means like
no in humans ever
I personally it's just a lot like I
don't know if we need it's so similar
it's like how when you know with the 10
Rings they didn't make them Rings they
made them like bracelets so they
wouldn't be like oh it's like The
Infinity Gauntlet all over it right they
want to have these like big differences
and the thing that makes the Inhumans
work in the comic books is that they're
the stories you can't tell with the
X-Men I don't know if we would tell a
story about a bunch of people on the
moon like the weird thing that makes
thin humans work I don't know if it will
translate to because eternals didn't do
that great so I don't know if they'll
tell the weird existential or Ponder
some out there kirbyisms yeah because I
don't think there's a market for it to
this level but they need to be educated
we need to get the propaganda out there
to the people get the weird do we have
to reach a thousand by Friday or like
can we do it by end of day Friday and
I'll cut my hair if we reach by the end
of the show on Friday end of the show
I'll cut my hair and we're gonna give
four choices and keep in mind that I do
have to officiate a wedding uh the
following week so be nice with the
choices
you're already we already voted oh you
guys already decided what kind of hair
yeah well we said we kind of want to do
a mullet on this stuff
I was gonna let the audience vote
just while you're away that he wants to
shave your chest yeah yeah I think 2K
was the chest shape all right all right
if you guys get if you guys raised 15
grand I'll shave my man meat my bad boy
Danny orange also had a Super Chat kind
of talking about uh how the cree could
be involved could the Creed be The
Originators of the MCU mutants instead
of the celestials essentially taking the
place of the 616 in humans ever
officially existing uh so it could be
interesting
I I wonder if like the freezing of
Tiamat maybe because isn't there
something in the comics about Tima dying
or the celestial dying on Earth and his
blood seeping into the ground and that's
why we have so many superpower people on
earth I think it's going to be Celestial
based I think it's going to be the
eternal's ending as I think what leads
to the expert he's got to be going
through a few aquifers you know
saturating things a little bit of a
message I think the birth of the
celestial in the planet caused an X Gene
oh they are that one that makes sense I
like the idea I think It ultimately will
be this celestials but I like more that
it would have been the cree and they
were just doing like experiments on us
uh ages ago and we were turning into
music alien probing yeah they were and I
would have loved to be probe to be a
mittens absolutely
that changes me like outwardly like you
know like yeah I don't want to walk
around as a giant Diamond I do yeah
they're a girl's best friend uh correct
corrupted next uh we're so sorry you're
corrupted uh they had a Super Chat when
the portal was open to the other realm I
believe uh you know the veil touches the
veil or whatever uh do you think the
time do you think for the time it was
open uh exposed the exchange to random
people is that possible and they call
you Al koi you predicted this great job
I did I called uh I called the
introduction of X-Men through Miss
Marvel like three months ago whoa
people on Twitter just like I said so
the last the problem is the last 14
years everyone's playing this and when
it actually happens you don't want to
join the
same like yeah okay with it but I hate
women it has become a trend of like I
did this and I'm like yeah I also farted
yesterday I mean check the real rejects
lots of the videos I've been saying the
real Rejects and on my tick tock on
record on Tick Tock that this would lead
to X-Men so only person allowed to say
it I will say this is my one I told you
the conspiracy theory part of me that
article on marvel.com today where they
interview people and like it was a
secret when they were filming the
episode like only a Manu for a little
bit and then even the actor played Bruno
he didn't know until like the day of
there was like a blank in the script
okay but this article that they put on
marvel.com does not say the word mutant
anywhere inside of it that's so smart
because it's not that way they didn't
mess up
honestly it just basically says at one
point like and yeah that music cue was a
big question but they have not said the
words
yeah yeah like are we in trouble
like are they not doing it like say it
someone's saying well I think when they
are going to say it is in nine days
okay so Marvel sets up their property so
one thing leads into another this is the
only time there's a gap this long and
comic-con's in the middle yeah I think
he's gonna come out and Kevin feige's
got a deadline and uh us we're gonna get
a lot of moments at that
black panther 2 trailer I know I've
waited so long it almost made me want to
go quick not starting Daniel that
trailer not featuring it made me almost
not want to see the movie that's it what
I said that's impossible new master hit
us again with twenty dollars that's
second donation from new master oh thank
you new man can we think Carol Van
Danvers had to sign the sokovia of
course absolutely not no she passed out
she said even if she was usually back
my theory isn't necessarily a Saturday
swap I think that the Bengal called her
into its pair I think there's someone
else wearing the other three angle but I
don't think uh Captain Marvel yeah is it
not following her from shangji because
she's in the she looks exactly the same
I I assumed she was coming from Captain
Marvel but that's what makes me think
that the Miss Marvel thing's unrelated
to the I don't think it's a swap I think
she got no no no yeah there's switched
places and I think that's where Miss
Marvel's the marbles is gonna pick up
exactly mid moment she's gonna be like
what do I do now and then somehow Monica
is going to come and try to help or
unless all three of them for some reason
got all Dosey dude I just still am like
I know Monica is gonna have a tie into
like clearly Captain Marvel by just
emotion and what's happened but I'm also
like how are you gonna tie her powers to
her when she got it through like one
division uh so I I don't know this is
for the marbles this has nothing to do
with what we're talking about also is
that a mutation if we're going through
that that's what we're talking about
we'll see if that's a mutation I still
think celestials is actually in the
Marvels Valkyrie yeah someone shared on
Twitter a photo of all the people that
are going to be in Marvel's and Valkyrie
was on it and I was like just because
she's black it doesn't mean she's gonna
be in this movie with all these pocs
because there's all because there's like
the directors of black woman and then
here we have uh Tiana Paris and then a
lot of pocs are in it and I was like I
don't think valkyrie's in this I do
think valkyrie's gonna become a bigger
part of the universe because I think
she's gonna get done with like being
king of Asgard I think she's out but I
think they're gonna start doing things
with Valkyrie and I think we're gonna
see more of her so it wouldn't surprise
me but it does seem weird like I I think
we'll see more of her but that one
doesn't fill out a check mark of where
I'd say like why okay maybe I was maybe
that person was you know Twitter
sometimes is not telling the truth Luke
Hemsworth should definitely be the new
king of oh he's making plays
yes it just becomes an artist commune
yes he's like well we're making content
now easy said uh tick tock house
yeah it's just Matt Damon and the
brother making like yeah trademark here
so that we can use it on our Tick Tock
account if I see it anywhere I'll kill
you
there's a YMCA character could a Jensen
Eckles playing oh what about Gambit
he's dirty that's cyclops oh he could be
uh because he cut apples right like so
Jensen Ackles as someone that like you
want to follow but it's kind of a dick
sometimes that like he's always he's
easy to fall in love with for Gene but
also like reluctantly he's got the voice
yeah the voice I say you make him Sauron
give him a pterodactyl head yeah keep
that great yeah
baby he's one of my threesomes when are
we gonna get thoron in the air that's a
great Gosling Jensen Ackles and Justin
Harley are my three Cycles hustling
wants to be someone else right Ghost
Rider I mean but Justin Hartley from
this is that's my third one though oh I
like Justin Hardin right because he was
Aquaman in the original and then and
then they made a pilot for a spin-off
didn't go well then he just had to
settle for this is us just six years of
drama making me cry I wanted to love to
see Jensen Nichols in anything but I
just think now seeing him as soldier boy
I'd only want to see him play at another
horror
very bad he was so good oh God also call
me Jensen Nichols
[Music]
did ask uh who do you think is gonna be
the next mutant you see Rogue right you
think that'll be the next is the Rogue
supposed to be in the Marvels they're
staying away from Jean Gray right now
right they got it thank you Jesus
if they immediately start the Phoenix
she's like floating in the sky with her
eyes rolled back like this is yeah I
can't sit through the Phoenix again I
love it
that's moving please stop doing it today
it's like the post-credit scene of the
Marvels and it's like
if I see him
I'm leaving I'm leaving I I agree with
Rogue
um uh really quick we'll just go we'll
we'll run through these really quick uh
Kat said what's your favorite moment in
Miss Marvel
um do you guys have a favorite moment
like in the whole show the whole show
we'll go really quick with these because
I love the I love the flashback I
thought the flashback uh the origin of
the family I thought that perhaps
episode four or five could have been
combined into one episode but I did
enjoy how we met the the characters that
were responsible for the family there
you go uh clearly the cinematography won
me over yeah there were some great shots
it was so beautiful that's immediately
what grabbed me yes I learned a lot
because I didn't know a lot about uh
anybody in the show for me uh she's
always been the modern silver age
Spider-Man Silver age Spider-Man is all
about his hometown his family trying to
balance work life and friendship all
those things make Spider-Man like my guy
Miss Marvel is all that plus she's from
a culture that I've never been really
exposed to I don't have a lot of Muslim
friends I'd like to I just don't know a
lot of people that are exposed to that
world as directly as the character so
I've Loved Miss Marvel because she
introduces me to cultures that I'm not a
part of and helps educate me on a thing
that I already feel close to because of
Spider-Man so my favorite thing was the
fact that she's the inverse spider makes
her family supports her so the
combination of all the family elements
with the costume and then the naming
being her name the Kamala as named by
her father Miss Marvel just made me
break that's my favorite moment oh
that's it's a long journey to get there
sorry but that's how I got it
like everybody else
my dad and I was like I jumped to me as
a younger person I was like yeah I would
be so irritated with my parents uh but
this episode the last episode with her
name I said this is the best dad I've
ever had when he's getting on the roof
and he's like nope
but that being about family and ancestry
tied in all the things I love about her
in one moment and that's like that
journey to land at that moment it's
great and last last really quick I'm so
sorry guys do you think from Fray girl
do you think sorry I can't read behind
the camera
gonna fall like Zach do you think Cleary
is working for sword or not oh yeah
looking for something yeah I said I
wanted to talk about this so we'll make
it's working for the weekend is what
he's doing I'm speaking of that we're
done no I'm just kidding I do think I I
love the theory that he's a scroll I
love that thing yeah but he's on the
good side yeah he's definitely work I
think he definitely has connections to
Fury he's he's like bad but good I think
he is working under Fury and he's at a
point where he's like good you can't do
that like why are you doing this you're
making you follow my distinct orders I
was also like are you gonna tell this
woman to follow her orders when she has
not been doing it the entire season
we're uh we're so close to another swear
Chrissy offered us to her three swear
words I think to send us out okay we
should just do her swear words because
we're almost there we're only six
dollars short I don't I hate rewarding
you people for failing me but I will do
it because my first day back and I'm
feeling nice and benevolent won't happen
again Chrissy's Norris curses I'll take
the one she said I did wrong which is
manvecter which means harsh fart not
stink fart so you're a bunch of men's
writers I'll take the next one uh you're
a real
hob-naz ultir which is a raven starver
you don't feed your Ravens well I pulled
a raven starver out of here and I wish I
could have showed you guys but I started
ripping them all into pieces because I
need to fiddle with stuff but that was a
good one you gotta do the last one uh
why okay I'm a bike step because you've
been acting like a pascali today I am
the world's greatest hits
hey that's it for the break room today
thank you for joining us thank you so
much for joining us uh for our live show
live for my break room yes this live
you'll never know where we live uh we
hope you tune in tomorrow uh and every
day this week uh let's see if we can get
Tommy's haircut by the end of the week
he really needs it uh but we appreciate
you all Breakers your roomies your trash
bags thanks for being here all right
we'll catch you tomorrow same place same
time same as she was there to cut his
hair